yourself and judi dench you haven't done  this yet you want to be working together  soon I believe we are in the movie of  cats  musical path who are you giving Gus is  the cat at the theater door my name as I  ought to have told you before is really  asparagus but that's such a fuss to  pronunce that they usually call me just  gas but look if you're making a group  I'm really the invitation is so so open  but you might well ask how did you  prepare for being a cat how do you  prepare for being a cat well at the  moment I'm looking for the inner [ __ ]  the mugginess that she's within us all  not doing very well at it I thought of  going on a cat's diet unit weekends just  eating cat food so yes that out but and  I've always thought that tinned cat food  smells as if it might be rather tasty it  isn't  [Music]